yo what's good it's lil pop I'm here
checking in with bootleg cab
podcast man we got a special guest in
here representing Jacksonville yeah
only one of them what's up man
it's good uh how are you enjoying uh BT
weekend well it's over now it's Monday
but yeah where's it Tuesday it's Tuesday
you know we'd be vapping you feel me
have a man have a vampire right now
event yeah you got the new album half
man half Vamp which is uh explain are
you like do you not sleep a lot do you
bite [__] in the neck and suck their
blood are you like uh are you into like
scared of garlic or what's going on nah
you know the [__] do get hooked
though okay but nah this is on some [__]
like
that's when when you feel me that's when
I go to work Strictly Business standing
on the business you know I'm saying ah
man you know that's that's when I'm
taking care of responsibilities in the
daytime all the responsibilities that I
created as a man family I love you fear
Memphis being the father of Big Brother
you know I'm saying little brother being
the uh of sun can I tell you what we
call Vamps in my friend group what's up
I have a friend and I'm not even lying
right now
shout out to the baby dude
we call him a vampire because he ate his
girl out while she was on her period
oh my God he's a real vampire just a
[__] psycho he got me beat yeah
yes he we say he's got his red he's got
his Red Wings you know sit down so I
mean I don't mind you know the the
period relations if you got the shower
and you know if it's
Britney's going crazy
so yo talk to me man because obviously
Jacksonville is one of the hottest
cities in hip-hop it's been uh very very
highly publicized a lot of the violence
that transpires out there
um
what do you think if anything can be
done to try to bring
I guess a lot more unity in Jacksonville
no it's really
it's really unity in Jacksonville
you just you know I'm saying everybody
everywhere you go you know I'm saying
everybody not gonna like each other or
be a parties I think you know I would be
like that so
the unity is not saying that the way it
is now you feel me it's good you feel
like it's getting better yeah everybody
just gotta you know I'm saying build
around that you feel me everybody might
not be on the same thing you can't force
that you feel me but as long as you on
the same page you know what I'm saying
is building trying to grow that's all
that matters 100 man what it's like for
you because you've been grinding
independently for so long what has been
the biggest thing that you've learned
since coming with CMG because obviously
you know I always say it like the
hottest label in the world you know what
I'm saying like it's really like the
modern day death Rowan so for you coming
into such a it's like the All-Star team
yeah you know what I mean it's crazy
when you really go through the roster
what is some stuff you've picked up
the future matters you know what I'm
saying but the brand you know I'm saying
that's it build the brand you know what
I'm saying like
right now you see how you saying like
CMG and he and got it got his artist you
feel me he making sure that that them
artists building their brand in the
process and you know what I'm saying
you know when he feel me don't get no
better than that you know what I'm
saying the brand that's all that matter
having something in the years from now
that's no I'm saying that that's still
here you feel me like he did
I like that
I would say who's the starting five of
CMG and then who's the Sixth Man or
woman
um
I can't put everybody you know what I'm
saying Yo Gotti's like LeBron James or
Michael Jordan right type [__] or you
know what he's like Greg Popovich at
this point you're trying to put like
together like like just like the
starting five just any anywhere type
[__] okay boom yeah you got your your
Jordan
we got it
he's the coach he's like the Hall of
Famer turn coach I'm serious man okay
you're the sixth man I'm coming out the
bench you're Lou Williams I'm coming out
the bench for show for sure you know
what I'm saying you can always depend on
me to come out the benching and throw 25
up win a game easy win a game seven easy
you feel me so one thing about that
starting five they know they can depend
on Pablo they can depend on you to come
on clean up
call me it's okay if you're in
Jacksonville there's no team nearby
there's like obviously the Hawks up top
and then down below it's really the
magic or the closest team like who do
you Orlando Magic
um
what in basketball yeah and basketball
I'm a LeBron James fan I love it I go
with LeBron go yeah and then in football
you obviously love the Jaguars or I mean
that hard job that's got to be tough
right just uh growing up watching like
uh mediocrity or subpar football your
whole childhood hey watch that
nah man you know you own a mark Burnell
Jersey or Nah mandatory I was a Maurice
Jones truth Jones Drew was a beast UCLA
man he was a very tiny tiny Stout dude I
was a Jones roof and that I had the
Jones did you play fantasy football
because he was a beast in fantasy film I
played fantasy football I ain't really
big on that I feel like people go to
Jacksonville to get good and then they
get traded
like Jalen Ramsey Jalen Ramsey we had
Leonard fournette fournette was a beast
had to go to he went to Tampa Bay he got
a ring one thing about we can we can
slip up a good roster I can't deny that
place Campbell who's there at all but
this team we got you know I'm saying
combination
I feel like we gonna be on Trevor
Lawrence yeah Trevor Lawrence holding it
down he ain't scared of nothing and he
out there playing on the east side well
you know I'm saying the heart of
Jacksonville it's my side so he good
that's where the stadium is yep have you
seen Trevor Lawrence out in public
anywhere yeah I don't see any trouble
Lawrence out in public I feel like you
guys like you should take him out like a
night on the town through little puppies
yeah for sure Trevor Lawrence if you
ever see this anybody if y'all get this
to travel along the Duval way
come on come aim it's the only way you
feel me you are playing on the east side
every day you feel me you coming through
my hood you know what I'm saying come on
why not stop doing
um for you man like obviously I just
looking you up on YouTube there's so
many like random documentaries about
your life and what's going on yeah how
much of that [__] is like frustrating
because I'm sure a lot of it is [__]
but people watch I mean a lot of the
stuff is tons of views so it's like
people watch that come to come to their
own conclusions like I can only imagine
if you look to me my name up and there
was people making many documentaries
about my life that was inaccurate I hate
them in a documentary so much because
and you never know what the guy looks
like it's just a voice everything false
yeah you feel me like it gonna take a
little pieces of it you know what I'm
saying of what you don't let out to the
world and everything else is just built
off their assumptions uh fans
assumptions it's all assumptions it's
like it's like they're trying to control
the name that [__] is so much false it's
so much fiction and then it's like
Right Out playing with people life
people Freedom like stop playing 100 man
[__] lame is here
um growing up in Jacksonville what are
you doing for fun are you hooping
obviously you're making music are you
watching Netflix you're playing 2K what
do you do for fun as a kid coming up
where you're from coming up in
Jacksonville like
it's best to like
be from
a hood a filmmakers ain't too much going
on like in like the nice areas
like nothing going on at all so if you
like in the hood then you've got
something going on every day like what
are you doing like I mean I'm talking
about like you getting in the streets
I'm talking about like no I ain't even
talking about like getting in the
streets like that's what a fun that you
feel me in the neighborhood like we used
to go to just ride ride to be able to go
outside and ride your bike every day you
know what I'm saying that was fun for us
like we didn't go nowhere you know what
I'm saying they consider it fun we had a
little [__] like Adventure Landing you
know what I'm saying like that was like
I look water park arcade but that [__]
was ran down you know I'm saying you got
the beach you feel me that's it but
other than that the neighborhood you
know I'm saying the the the neighborhood
pool going to the Kennedy Center
no idea
I just be like yeah yeah that's right
[__] especially if the water's cold
it'll warm you up bro okay don't let
that water be too cold yeah pissing this
water real quick so I got the chlorine
for a reason you know what I'm saying uh
yeah we got lighters everywhere
yeah come on
oh Brittany you know this is one of the
only
on the interviews you get the smoke on
so why not smoking
where'd you go to where were you guys at
before this
uh
um
I'm assuming you're not smoking at
serious right no no
I don't even know that's
cool my face looks weird you stole
Christmas laptop well I won't go down
that uh rabbit hole with you and my
thoughts
what was on there
was there was there oh [__]
see she's a thief
just know the newest employee of CMG
steals
and she's the interview Nazi Mane you
know I mean I can't wait to get her
notes after this one
um
she'll be like can you edit out all of
the marijuana
would you start smoking weed how old
were you I was it's crazy I started
smoking late I was like 17 18. okay
smoking that's not terrible I smoked
weed for the first time when I was eight
but I didn't like get into it but I
tried it for the first time when I was
saying I smoked for the first time too
when I was like 12. and it burned like I
just remember being like it hurt I'm
like how why do people how do people do
this yeah I remember getting high for
the first time I like what's the point
have you ever smoked out of a soda can
some holes in the middle of that [__]
you smoke out of an apple
I ain't smoking I don't know Apple
neither
it's a thing you know I used to live in
Florida I used to live in Tampa which is
not obviously very close to where you're
at but it ain't fun either not far
either right in the middle man right in
the middle how much uh do you still try
to pay attention to like the new wave of
what's going on at a Jacksonville and
like maybe try to help out like if
there's somebody you're feeling that it
is and signed you you're gonna throw
them a free feature look out for sure
for sure uh you're talking about like in
Jacksonville yeah just in your city um
I like I don't really be like on social
media like that like so when I
um when I do hear something like new
like new artists coming out of
Jacksonville my little brother put me on
it right you know what I'm saying and
and if he rocking with it if you think
it's hard then it's hard because he just
listening to know anything he like me
when it comes to music so when you're
recording are you writing [__] down are
you punching in like give me your
process what's your process when you're
recording
punching in I go into I go in the studio
you know what I'm saying pull me up some
beats go through some beats I'll
probably send by a good
10 of them you know what I'm saying and
I'm gonna try to do at least five of
them at that 10 pack before the night
over it
so you're like hum like a melody and
then go in and
yep honestly that's it you're pretty
you're a lot more melodic than a lot of
the Jacksonville [__] that's popping
like in terms of like you know you
actually have a lot of Melody in your
music so yeah a lot of the other [__]
like it's just very like you know I want
to learn how to aggressive yeah I wanna
know how to sing it's a definitely a lot
of regression coming out of Jacksonville
but it's a lot of you feel me it's a lot
hey yko service you feel me it's a lot
of you know what I'm saying it's a lot
of Versatility I don't know what I'm
saying she's got to be I feel like
there's somebody else I'm forgetting
that sings for my tripping
oh it's a lot
like Hill Cyrus shout out I know for
sure you gotta get your [__] together
right here you can sing for sure no
sorry saying you could probably help him
out right do a record with him
throw him the lot man yeah I mean he'll
make money that little Papa live after
recent events leave it in God's hands
for sure
um yo hey let's stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good Folks
at King Palm that's right man shout out
to King Palm uh we're talking about
nothing but that organic all right that
natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say man
we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg or bootleg have
try either one of those I forget which
one it is it's bootleg or it's bootleg
Kev you know what the correct promo code
will be down below use the one that's
down here kingpom.com get 50 off right
now shout out to King pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discretely of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going in
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you can tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right bluetooth.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're gonna give you a
month's supply for free just five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview
no like tell me because obviously you
um you've been rapping how many years
has it been
I wrote my first round when I was eight
but for your first time like you dropped
an actual project oh
officially oh yeah
oh no hell not in that's the case
by 2013. um yeah 2013 I probably
uploaded my first song of SoundCloud
damn so you're like low-key you've been
doing this [__] you ain't you ain't like
a you're a new artist but you're not a
new artist not at all I've been growing
I don't seen
like I don't see in a lot of different
eras in this music [__] you feel me you
gotta think like I was born in 2000 you
know what I'm saying when 2 000 hit who
was popping
[__] really 50 Nelly you know what I'm
saying so by the time 2002 you able to
talking you know what I'm saying my mama
told me [__] I was able to
it's your birthday you know I'm saying
that whole song that was two years old
it's getting hot in here take off all
your clothes I know this is my mama told
me she said you know I was you know I'm
saying I was meant for this [__] you
know what I'm saying just thought that
you were two years old singing two years
old like you know how to learn that [__]
yeah you know how that [__] go you two
years old you hit a little song popping
in yeah so I'm pretty sure she did that
right is there an air you say you've
seen a lot of Errors of hip-hop what era
do you miss the most
that's a good question I probably missed
that
what year that was when when Wayne
dropped like Hustler music I was awake
music was Cardiff two yes here so that
was like
2006. I said I go back there when you
were six years old yeah I'd probably go
better there when I was like when 106
apart was heavy and all that and Lil
Wayne Lil Wayne the purple you remember
who you like who's your favorite host
because there's so many iterations of
106 and Park hosts I got to go original
probably AJ and free agent freeze the I
mean that's the show I don't even
remember who I was hosting I think Big
Tigger hosted it for a little bit yeah I
just know I hosted it a little bit and
then Thursday Bow Wow hosted it that's
right Terence J Terence was good too
shots of Terrence I forgot about Bow Wow
I feel like Pro was good when they were
when they hosted two when I was a little
kid I thought a little bow wow owned 106
and Park like I thought he just had some
steak in it because he was on that
[__] yeah shout out to bow out
and little Romeo it's crazy how about I
keep coming up man I've been paying
about my homies to buy
people looked at me like I was crazy you
know what I'm saying because I was
paying how much power are they like now
but I'm telling me I like about the
reason I'm here during this interview
like come on if you want to be technical
bro that man bro I'm you got a thing I
just told you I don't see you everywhere
now you got a thing I'm watching a
little bow I don't want to sits apart
like damn I can do that [__] I'm gonna
do that one day so Bow Wow
Come on one of the reasons you feel me
the show for sure you know hey Bow Wow
Loki I would say we gotta put a little
more respect on Bow Wow's name
pull it up in that Bentley on on fresh
as I miss video come on gotta go get me
one it's actually my favorite Bow Wow I
gotta go get me one of them what was the
other one where he did the awkward like
let me hold you was that that was like
all right let me hold you yeah I told
myself then if you can do it I can do it
[__] that's it yeah that's fair that's
fair who's your goat like who's the
greatest of all time to you in terms of
hip-hop [__] Michael
foreign
like living in Florida like you know how
like people be like oh
like when they come to park and [__]
they like Park got a song for every
situation type [__] that's why they
didn't know all right he got a song for
every situation you know it's funny
because like I didn't unders because I'm
a West Coast guy but I lived in Tampa
for like three years yeah I lived there
when he got out the last time he got out
and
I didn't I I always like enjoyed boozy
music and [__] and him and Webby [__]
but I didn't really understand like
the gravity of what he means to the
South until I lived there and uh when he
put his album out I think he called it
like
boopac or some [__]
I was like I get it because he's a lot
of people's Tupac yeah you gotta listen
to that he's a lot of people's Tupac for
real like listen to that throwback boost
yeah and he's he's he looked like kid
did you meet him uh have you met him yet
yeah I don't know it was he didn't
disappoint did he uh no he it was crazy
because he knew me he feels right like
just you know what I'm saying me being
on him growing up you feel me like how
it was on him [__] and now you see me
you know me his kids don't know what I'm
saying listen to my music famous it's
got a lot of them yeah my name streams
up if you get all the Boosie's kids
together that's a stream Farm if you
wanted it to be
um
I always tell I tell everybody boozy
like when you meet him because I've met
a lot of my favorite rappers growing up
and like I've been disappointed by a few
of them like where they were either just
not who I thought they were and they
were [__] not him he's like as
advertised yeah not for sure he was
cutting up at the BT Awards too man
definitely yeah did you see him fall
when he was ripped trying to rip the
plastic off of himself when Lotto was
performing nice see that it's so funny
oh [__]
um for you like do you have I mean you
could educate me do you have like an
imprint a label yourself that you're
yeah like the wild child when you hear
Wild Child I see the chain wow child
that's that's your label that's the
brand for sure for sure okay a couple
years from now you're gonna see that
[__] everywhere not even a couple years
I give it a year
do you like have you have you um
you know try to get some advice from
Gotti like hey once I'm ready to start
signing artists what's the show for sure
yeah for sure have you gone to a soccer
game with him yet because he owns a
soccer team no not yet where's the team
at is it in DC yeah DC yeah I feel like
that's I definitely gotta catch him who
was just talking about soccer too I got
a kiss have you been to the casino with
him no I feel like you shouldn't go
because I saw a video of him and I think
he like lost like a
Preposterous amount of money so you
think I eat things he ain't one thing
about it I think Jay-Z might have been
standing there and getting sweating you
think about I'd be that good be that
good that look so this is the thing if
you go gambling with somebody
who's willing to like put six figures on
like a single spinner hand yeah
then you start thinking in your head
it's a good idea
and then you might try to like not see
me personally I gamble I ain't no
Gambler well what do they got like a
hard rock somewhere over there in
Jacksonville I think there's one in
every major floor no in Jacksonville I
don't got nothing but like little Best
Bets the closest Hard Rock would
probably be like um Tampa
oh I've had some nights at that
[__] yeah
have you ever have you been to Vegas
yeah I haven't been to Vegas I love
Vegas did you notice the random
prostitutes late at night sitting at
slot machines by themselves while they
had baby fat purses hanging from their
arms no I never noticed that yeah it's a
thing yeah yeah you go to bake ice
living Vegas I've lived everywhere you
go to Vegas if it's three in the morning
and you see a chick that's like a six or
better
she's at that slot machine by herself
and she's done up like you know like oh
you look like you might have just left
the club yeah or a job interview she's a
prostitute
for sure
or any casino you go to you go to the
high limits room and you go to the high
limit bar and there's just a plethora
that's where the wonderful ones are the
Casino floors where you know the lot
lizards are as we like that limited
looking for the bottles yeah yep yep yep
but if you ever go to the Tampa Bay Hard
Rock they're all disgusting
is bad
I've never participated in such
activities but I am very very uh you
know aware of my surroundings at all
times I'd like to know what's going on
gotta watch us around
um like it's crazy because you you call
yourself hap Vamp or half Vamp has like
any of um Playboy Cardi's interesting
cult following of
white kids with dirty air forces come
out of the Woodworks saying wear The
Vamps nah I get a lot of I get a lot of
card fast
I've been trying to be like putting
comments and [__] yeah I'd be trying to
Carter fans chill man you should tell
them there's more than one vampire
obviously they never said it don't tell
anything stop making events when they
made Carter you feel Miss different type
of events what's the best vampire movie
it what's that what's that one
it's like a
what's that there's Lost Boys there's
blade there's no there's also some
really really suspects with that movie
what's that one at
good at a lot of things but acting is
not probably at the top of the you know
he's all right yeah but he he's good he
good [__] [__] [__] you feel me like
come on Soul Plane
[__] A lot of people don't like Soul
playing Soul Plane the hood classic it's
definitely a hood classical I sold
copies of it as a young child uh that's
how you got named bootleg yo yes for
sure precisely sir respect
Soul Plane put Kevin Hart on don't you
ever forget it definitely
first Kevin Hart movie I remember
watching I mean Soul Plane me too Tom
Arnold was in Soul Plane that was his
last great moment too yeah so playing do
you know who Tom Arnold is no you ever
watch Roseanne nope damn we grew up
different then I'm telling you a lot of
movies a lot of movies you probably have
caught up no Roseanne with the white
lady and the her her [__] families
from like the like the 90s it was
probably it was like a sitcom about a
family the Connors no you never seen it
was that jeez what TV shows besides 106
and Park did you like well what are you
watching right now do you watch do you
like binge watch anything or are you on
Netflix checking out documentaries yeah
I like um
manifest I heard manifest is good yeah
Manifesto I just finished manifest
um
what's this [__] is oh Tyree
the the ghost series retiree that's your
dog oh ghost okay yeah I'm rocking with
that
um I missed the whole Power Wave just
it's a couple I got in this crazy I got
on the power with with the ghost series
like the little tired yes she went back
yeah
um
it's a couple honestly but I know
manifest probably like the best thing
going right now manifest manifest I just
finished snowfall I was rocking with
snowfall everything I was really
watching it just came to the end like
season finalities and [__] so I'm really
trying to find new [__] to watch I love
snowfall snowfall had me wondering what
crack would be like to take you know
but it definitely made me be like
because you know there's like the the
part of the show where
um
Franklin Saints girlfriend smokes crack
the cop's daughter yeah and in one
episode her whole [__] just gets
everything just went outside she ends up
like in a [__] crazy they say that
having sex selling her dad's jewelry and
I'm like damn I said I first hit that
first hit like so it just makes you
wonder like
you feel me like is it good I ain't
gonna lie a crackhead told me that first
hit
is like I think they're like chasing it
the rest of their life yeah you know
what I'm saying and then they end up you
know naked show over here you know what
I'm saying okay
are there a lot of homeless people in
Jacksonville
yes a lot of homeless people everywhere
man no there's a lot of homeless people
here you can do something about it
listen here you're in L.A we got we are
like the [__] LeBron James the
homeless people bruh this is so crazy I
just we are the goddamn Coca-Cola of the
homeless I'll be wishing I could do
something about it man like we're like
Thursday on the street but I know I know
it's it's going it's gone one day what
is it I gotta ask you right because your
guys's Governor is probably gonna he's
running for president Ron DeSantis and
he has a lot of divisive policies about
he's banned uh certain black studies in
the universities and
he's trying to ban all the wokeness any
thoughts on Rhonda said this little Papa
uh you actually just brought that into
my attention you know what I'm saying
first person bringing into my attention
but I mean
we just I just look at it like is
everything good in Florida like when
you're living there are you like I like
the way he's running [__] exactly not
because or I don't I don't notice the
policies yeah because I don't live in
Florida no more he's smart man I'm just
yeah I'm just from that you know what
I'm saying so it's like I don't really
be knowing I feel like especially if
you're from Jacksonville once you get
popping get the [__] out of there
respectfully of course you know maybe go
back if you guys you know go to the
playoffs or something
that game was against the Chargers gaffy
that game this year yeah
of the year I mean I was at that game
yeah it made me be like okay that's why
they did that because you were there
yeah you're the lucky charm yeah well
you're not yeah you're not I mean you're
you're like uh yeah was that what you
said was that was that said correctly I
didn't just call you a leprechaun yeah I
said lucky charm
yeah they did that while shout out to
the job while they they had me a little
Jersey though when I got that little
Papa you know what I'm saying that's
fireman yeah what's your favorite cereal
speaking of Lucky Charms fruity pelvis
40 Pebbles are gas fruity pelvis and
then you got to go Frosted Flakes
all right uh have you ever been at the
bottom of a bunch of cereal at the same
time like all the cereals are low and
then you just combine them into like a
Super Bowl of cereals yeah mess around
with Q3 that [__] is fire I had no
choice
gotta stop the interview to say about
our good Folks at Odd Socks baby yeah
shout out to odd talks now this is what
I love about Odd Socks one their family
we love them but also they have the most
comfortable socks in the [__] world
all right now look they got the craziest
licenses you see the Jolly Rancher these
are actually flies [__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the Odd Socks Basics now
these are just the basic socks so these
are in my bag because I'm taking these
I love these odd talks basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps oh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview it's
kind of like with that kind of like a be
a decent analogy of your new album it's
like the super cereal bowl of hip-hop
right now
yeah exactly you see I'm Number well at
number six it's your sixth album no I'm
talking about wow
um on Apple music congratulations yeah I
appreciate that who's ahead I'm trying
to go top five you will
what you got to do is you just gotta
like you know push your fans we're gonna
try to get top five I don't care if
anybody wants to buy it again real talk
and got it push that [__] man go top
five it just came out Friday yeah it
just came out Friday only one week of
promo too what has been your uh like you
know when you usually drop an album
you'll notice feedback about like do
what what song you're getting the most
feedback on that you feel like the is a
fan favorite
um
surprisingly
probably like I've been seeing a lot of
can't find it and problems back home
problems back home problems back home
but I wasn't surprised that that was
going to be a fan favorite right
I had them posted
um a little clip of the song and they
was asking for how many uh videos have
you shot or I'm sure you got some in the
can I had two already well three already
released stop going Mia
my Nova Mata and Chrome Heart make sure
y'all go check the market streaming them
up and then I got um do you like to wear
Chrome Heart Clothing yeah all right
with chrome heart so I was at uh the
mall in Vegas like two days ago yeah at
the win
and they had a Chrome Heart store in
there yeah and I walked in there and I
said
I'm gonna give this cheesy ass cornhart
[__] a chance and I went in there
and I just I just couldn't do it man I
feel like I would have walked out of
there dressed like Chris Jericho or
something bro like
you just gotta know how to see the thing
is this is the thing right is a lot of
people can wear the designer
but I would have the designer wearing me
type [__] that's what I'm saying I like
a pro club actually got to be in you not
on you it's definitely you feel me the
designer thing is not on me or in me see
that's what I'm saying now you can get
you a stylist if you feel like that see
I'm 36 with with children yeah and I
feel like the the fitted and the T and
the nice pair of shoes yeah
is kind of just where I'm at in life
yeah like see me if I was like at the
Grammys yeah I would see if Pro Club
could make me a suit
you know just give me the Pro Club soup
that's right see me I'll be on some [__]
on some chill [__] I don't really be
alone like dressing up news you know
what I'm saying like you see me it's a
great Vape sweater you guys appreciate
it you feel me it's chill [__] I go get
me
what is your advice in terms of what you
spend the most money on that you that is
irresponsible
they like to go to restaurants a lot
which is mine obviously I'm finally see
me uh some people like sneakers which is
another bicycle some people like cars
jewelry what is your biggest like I like
to splurge on this all right sneakers
clothes sneakers Jordans fashion
um yeah yeah Jordans I'm a bit Snicker
head so Jordan I'm one of the people
that feel like I gotta get every pill
Joy like every Jordan I draw yeah I got
to that point about a month ago and uh
I've looked at my my man cave and it's
just full of shoes and I was just like
these fools just got there me too they
got me I just did I just cleaned out my
pants I'm not even gonna win it did the
same [__] yep I did the same [__] I'm
gonna get majority of them away though
you know what I'm saying back to the
city you should sell them or or donate
them yeah yeah I'm gonna donate them and
then I got a sign on too so you got to
get every Jordan how old is yourself one
one yeah
has he shat on you yet
so that's not on my hand like this but
you ever had anything out on my hand one
thing about me yeah he did me you feed
me way better than he did his mom like
hmm [__] on me
my kid yeah he pissed but that's about
it other than that yeah yeah other than
that mom's got to work yeah
would you say having a kid kind of
change the way you look at the world and
the show priorities the show
definitely and it made me go 10 times
harder yeah what's up you know speaking
of we got to do a live read speaking of
going 10 times harder
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and you'll get a month's supply
for free Brittany
don't forget to go to Bluetooth for all
your men's
get them on that Bluetooth use that
promo code bootleg and get a month of
supply for free
just stay sponsor the [__] show what
do you want from me I couldn't
I couldn't not use the Segway that he
just gave me to promote it well listen
the album is out right now
um
how many albums all together you got oh
seven this made Seven yeah damn
you already have like a careers worth of
Music out yep that's the and I'm gonna
keep going into Till I Retire uh are we
considering this a mixtape or an album
it's a mystery album on the way
when I'm working how many songs are are
in that folder how many do you know are
like these are going on the album oh
that I don't know yet but I know I got
over a hundred and release more than 100
really songs yeah over 100 really songs
100 of them okay well listen little Papa
the new project mixtape whatever it is
and I'm glad to know that you're not out
here you know doing vampire [__]
literally because that would be super
illegal
super illegal yeah
yeah also if you you know never mind I
was gonna say you could do some vampire
[__] like my friend would that be gross
because
um
tell your tell your friend to blame
twice if you're okay he's a sick bastard
you're watching this so Papa we
appreciate you man I appreciate you for
having me there it is
boom hey this interview is brought to
you by our good Folks at hardean all
right shout out to the hardeen family in
Las Vegas make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the number
one dispensary period all right the
craziest selection of previous premium
cannabis you could ask for plus when you
go to Hardy in Las vegas.com you can
check out all the other cool stuff they
got going on you know they got a whole
weed University happening in Vegas
hardine is where it's at all right so if
you're in Las Vegas you get into that
taxi cab you say take me to Jardine and
when you get there you tell the
wonderful Bud tenders that I sent you
and they're going to take care of you
Harding underscore Las Vegas go follow
them and uh yeah we got another
interview coming soon